question for trex from logan logan asks
what is your opinion on mass gainers i
ask because i travel frequently for work
which makes bulking very difficult
without eating a lot of junk
currently i eat relatively quote unquote
clean for all meals and consume a mass
gainer to hit my calorie goal
so logan's consuming mass gainers
doing that instead of eating a bunch of
junk food
what is your opinion on mass gainers in
general and
in logan's specific situation does that
seem like a
a pretty decent compromise yeah so
mass gainers i generally have a negative
view of them
um but that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily a problem
so if you want to go that route and use
a mass gainer that's totally fine
i just think that they have i think they
have a reputation that's way better than
they deserve
so i used to use mass gainers when i was
in like high school
i really needed to gain weight for
wrestling and so i would uh
eat a full breakfast and then throughout
my first class of the day
drink a mass gainer which was like a
thousand calories
and then during my second class um i've
always been the way i am
in terms of just genuinely not caring
about food
if you know my lasagna recipe you know
all about this
but when i was in high school i would
just bring uh plain pieces of bread to
class and just
eat slices of like wonder bread during
class
but uh yeah i've never really cared it's
always just like get the calories in so
if you're just trying to get the
calories in mass gainers are fine but
the reason i think that they're
they get treated uh they get more
respect than they deserve
is we're basically looking when we look
at a weight gainer we're looking at a
whey protein shake
with just a really boring ass
carbohydrate like maltodextrin
just all over the place so they're
pretty much
giving you here's some whey protein and
we got to get the calories from
somewhere so we're going to put a
generally boring carb source in there
just for the sake of energy and so my
my approach to trying to gain weight is
why not just get a good whey protein
and then just eat something really cool
with it so like
i you know you mentioned in the in the
question
you're trying to bulk without eating a
lot of junk i guess
the disconnect between me and mass
gainers is
i don't see them as non-junk i see it as
a whey protein shake with a ton of just
boring calories mixed in but nothing
particularly beneficial
yeah and just so we're on the same page
here uh
maltodextrin is for all intents and
purposes sugar
it's just a a relatively short chain of
d-glucose
molecules um all linked together
those are super easy bonds to break i i
think that um
i think a lot of times people are too
quick to label things as
essentially sugar but maltodextrin is
essentially sugar like it's it's
literally just glucose probably within
10 minutes of hitting your stomach right
yeah and so if someone were to tell me
like
i'm gonna switch from having a mass
gainer
to having whey protein and two candy
bars
is that have i made a
step down like am i now eating junk
where i used to be eating good food
i would say you're pretty much at the
same place we're talking about getting
in whey protein with some amount of
calories and frankly
whether you're getting your calories
from a candy bar a pop-tart or
just a huge serving of maltodextrin
i don't really see those as being
particularly different
and so you know i've had i've taught a
bunch of beginning weight training
classes greg you have as well
a lot of times you'll get somebody who's
like i'm desperate to gain weight
what do i do and i'm like get enough
protein throughout the day
ways a convenient way to do that and
just like eat a candy bar drink a
mountain dew
just whatever it takes if you're really
struggling to get in
like some solid food just go for
whatever is easy to get down
and so i think for me the thing that's
interesting about
weight gainers is people view them as
being better than
junk food and i think it's just because
supplements
companies put their stamp of approval on
it and
that's something you see for instance
when people get really negative about
artificial sweeteners
you'll see them talk a lot about diet
sodas but
they won't worry about the fact like how
come every fitness supplement
i consume is sweet but doesn't have
sugar in it
it's like well because there's just
artificial sweeteners everywhere in it
right but like you'll see people
demonize diet coke but i very rarely see
the
the situation where people highlight the
amount of artificial sweeteners in their
amino acid product or their protein
product or like their pre-workout
or their pre-workout yeah so um i think
there's something about the fact that it
comes from a
fitness-oriented company that makes you
feel like okay
they wouldn't put anything out if it
were junk food but in reality i just i
don't see a huge difference when i look
at a weight gainer versus
a scoop away protein and like six
pop-tarts to me they're pretty
equivalent but
again that doesn't mean that it's like
inherently
stupid to have a mass gainer if if
that's convenient for you and you like
the flavor of the mass gainer and it
works for you that's totally fine you're
not losing anything
but i think a lot of people are
restricting their food choices
unnecessarily where they would be
totally fine if they just got a pretty
generic whey protein product
and just ate whatever food they really
really love to eat which is probably
gonna make them
enjoy that process a lot more yeah i i
mean
for logan's situation specifically if
he's traveling a lot
it it kind of depends whether it's
airport travel or not
um because if it is like you have issues
bringing
pretty much any kind of food with any
water content through security
um but you know if it's just like you're
on the road a lot
like wave shakes and bananas are fine uh
you know you can leave bananas in a hot
car all day
i have done it many times they're dirt
cheap uh there's probably going to be
some sort of grocery store essentially
anywhere you would travel to
it's cheap and quick to pick up some
bananas uh
that would probably be a better option
just a way shake and bananas or
really any kind of food you like and if
you're worried about it staying fresh
just like take a small cooler with you
put like
one or two little ice packs in the
bottom fill it up with [ __ ] apples or
oranges or
whatever you want um that would probably
be about as easy as a mass gainer
uh more nutritious and probably tastier
too
yeah and i i kind of painted the picture
of comparing
a mass gainer to just junk food
the best case scenario would be you
you're also getting some nutrients and
while you're doing this right
so like you said a banana some fruit
whatever whatever you want to take in
if you could get in some some some
source of calories that also brings
nutrients with it that's great
usually when people use these it's on
top of a base diet that has plenty of
fruits and vegetables and it's like
i just need the calories and and when
people need the calories and they're
struggling because their appetite is
just
totally shot and they're like how do i
get calories in without feeling gross
of course weight can't wait weight
gainers are a way to do that it's
totally fine
but i always like to make sure people
realize like if you don't want the
weight gainer you could just have whey
and like
literally your favorite food